we're now joined by kendall roy why did
you get involved why did you back out i
saw their plan and my dad's plan was
better ladies and gentlemen
the first [ __ ] thing my son's ever
done right in his life
we need to discuss this bear hug stick
or sell i think you should fight and
you're the one who built it all
kendall and roman will act as co-chief
operating officers he tried to help your
oldest enemy to take over and he gets my
promotion
i'd like to ask you to come in and be
the next chief executive of this company
i'm still applying for the job of
president of the united states do you
think that that's like a natural
progression from never done nothing
never to most important job in the world
we're going for pgm we leverage up and
eat pierce we're too big for sandy and
stewie to come from
welcome to turn haven our city on the
hill i have to ask any thought given to
whom you might hand over the keys just
tell him it's gonna be me
[ __ ] off
we had a tip-off some time ago new york
magazine working on a substantial piece
data wipes ndas cruise malpractice so
you know when you had me destroy those
documents at cruises i kept a few
where are they those papers i'll never
tell
the shareholder votes could be close
could you seduce
married that's not equivalent to think
about it i get it so let it
what did you know about wrongdoing by
means of the keeping of shadow logs i
believe my son was across that operation
you think we're through knowing the
shareholders time for the blood
sacrifice
so whose big hairy flip's gonna fit in
the glass slipper tom looks logical what
i have to be an honest broker
i'm really pretty unhappy being with you
i like her dad
i just don't want you [ __ ] on drugs
and she's part of it
you're across the cleanup the optics
make sense
now
you're the face
you're not a killer
you have to be a killer
i have an announcement to make
about wrongdoing at waystar roy cove the
truth is that my father is a malignant
presence a bully and a liar
and this is the day
his reign ends
you